bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce 28 avril
en corse la participation des gendarmes
à la destruction d'une période près
d'ajaccio devient la sphère de l'état
selon l'expression de lionel jospin elle
enquête judiciaire dévoile peu à peu les
2sous de l'opération de l'unité spéciale
de la gendarmerie à belgrade slobodan
milosevic ne supporte plus les
déclarations de son vice fois ministre
vuc dragovic et le limoge la carte
diplomatique se complique après cinq
semaines de conflit engagé au kosovo une
nouvelle vague impressionnante de
réfugiés est arrivé en albanie et en
macédoine et témoigne de massacrer
d'exécution reportage pas de coût cash
avec l'autre sans père et en macédoine
avec richard binet pressentant peut-être
le danger politique le premier ministre
monsieur lionel jospin et plusieurs
membres de son gouvernement sont
intervenus à l'assemblée nationale sur
la sphère de l'incendié d'un restaurant
du golfe d'ajaccio où des gendarmes dont
un colonel semble bien avoir joué un
rôle déterminant mais pour le chef du
gouvernement
la mise en cause des gendarmes n'est pas
une affaire d'état mais la sphère de
l'état reste à savoir si cette subtilité
de langage résistera à l' enquête sur
cette journée politique consacrée à la
corse le récit de laurent hakim avec
joseph gaschy qu un gouvernement sur le
grill toute la journée sollicité pour
s'expliquer sur la sphère corse
premier rendez vous ce matin à l'elysée
autour du chef de l'état en conseil des
ministres jacques chirac demande que les
faits soient éclaircies et les
responsabilités établies
le ministre de l'intérieur en prends
l'engagement et dénonce les tentatives
d'amalgamés les licences
croyez moi j'ai regardé j'ai tout
jugement précipité
j'entends d assimilation au rainbow
warrior ça n'a pas de chance les droites
deuxième orale cet après midi devant les
députés l'ambiance est surchauffée pour
écouter les explications des ministres
de la justice de l'intérieur et du
premier ministre lionel jospin
réaffirmant son soutien au préfet bonnet
il annonce les premières sanctions
contre les trois officiers de
gendarmerie mis en cause il récuse
surtout toute implication au sommet de
l'état evènement sont bien une affaire
de l'état puisque certains de ces
services sont mises en cause
mais ce n'est pas une affaire d'état car
aucun des responsables politiques de
l'état qu'il s'agisse du premier
ministre qui vous parle
qu'il s'agisse du ministre de la défense
ou qu'il s'agisse du ministre de
l'intérieur
n'étant quelque façon que ce soit
intervenu dans ces événements je vous le
confirme lionel jospin n'aura pas
convaincu tout le monde de l'opposition
continuent à demander des comptes c'est
la duplicité ou l'incapacité je ne vois
pas comment on sort de ce dilemme
il reste bien sûr à démontrer que ceux
qui sont mis en cause aujourd'hui sont
les vrais responsables
cela il appartient à la justice de le
trancher je ne peux pas le dire à sa
place mais nous avons besoin dans cette
affaire de procédure qui aille assez
vite troisième mise au point de la
journée celle d'alain richard le
ministre de la défense qui a autorité
sur la gendarmerie c'est lui qui a
suspendu les trois officiers mais pour
des raisons pour le moment bien limiter
ce qui est avéré le seul point sur
lequel il me reviennent de me prononcer
à l'instant c'est que le colonel mazères
et le capitaine en brosse n'ont pas
rendu compte de la situation dans
laquelle s'était trouvée
le groupe concerné et donc j'ai prononcé
leur suspension fin d'une journée
d'explication il en faudra certainement
beaucoup d'autres pour faire la clarté
sur cette affaire et peu à peu on prend
connaissance des détails de l'opération
menée par les gendarmes les hommes du
groupe de pelotons de sécurité semblent
avoir mené une véritable opération de
commando sur la plage de cala doors ou
dans le golfe d'ajaccio reportage
olivier théron et diane richard les
gendarmes reviennent à la paillote huit
jours après l incendie criminel ils
viennent empêcher qu'ils féraud le
propriétaire ne puisse la reconstruire
pour la saison ils viennent surtout gelé
la zone pour que de nouvelles
investigations puisse s'y dérouler car
c'est ici que l'on a retrouvé les traces
matérielles du passage des trois
gendarmes du gps un radio émetteurs
comme tomber par terre un poignard
équipé d'une boussole une cagoule tachés
de sang près de la mer et enfin des
jerrycans rouge sur la plage le parfait
techniquement commando l'explication des
gendarmes du gps appuyés par leur chef
le colonel mézères c'est la thèse de
l'embuscade
ces hommes étaient en observation l'
incendie s'est déclaré
ils ont eu peur et ont pris la fuite
mais del enquête en flagrant délit menée
par le procureur baleste les
invraisemblances et les points
d'interrogation s'accumulent
comment des commandos surentraînés
ont-ils pu s'enfuir sans même signalé
lincendie qu'observée t-il dans cette
zone très peu habité à 3 heures du matin
pourquoi le capitaine en broche patron
du gps est blessé dans l'incendié at il
été déclaré officiellement en permission
juste après les faits ce qui a troublé
les enquêteurs lors de la garde à vue
ce sont aussi toutes les incohérences
les imprécisions dans les versions
fournies par les gendarmes
des gendarmes qui eux nient en bloc
avoir été les auteurs de l'incendié
transférer la nuit dernière de la prison
de borgo à la santé à paris pour des
raisons de sécurité le colonel mazères
par la voix de son avocat mario stasi
réaffirme son innocence - comment
avez-vous trouvé votre client à la
déterminé à faire valoir la vérité qui
n'est pas forcément ce que l'on raconte
de cette affaire c'est tout
dans quel état d'esprit est il
actuellement de ce premier set kirk
entre le mmm se trouve détenu mais
comme on pouvait l'espérer j'espère bien
pouvoir s'expliquer demain dès demain le
juge d'instruction procédera à un débat
contradictoire avec chacun des quatre
gendarmes
il devrait aussi se rendre sur les lieux
parallèlement à l'instruction une
enquête administrative et une enquête de
l'inspection générale de la gendarmerie
sont ouvertes
le capitaine en brosse le patron du gps
qui soignait ses blessures à toulouse
serait lui sur le point d'être mise en
examen et écroué la précision importante
ce ne sont pas des gendarmes ordinaires
qui sont mis en cause se sont d un
spécialement entraînés pour les missions
de surveillance et qu'ils avaient été
choisis pour travailler auprès du préfet
explications sur ce groupe de peu le ton
de sécurité avaient tiré curtet l'unité
est créée juste après la mort du préfet
erignac dans la crise que traverse alors
la corse
l'état estime que le nouveau préfet
bernard bonnet a besoin d'une force de
choc la gendarmerie créé gps sans être
un groupe d'élite les gendarmes tous
volontaires sont triés sur le volet ils
partent sans leur famille pour être
totalement disponible 95 hommes
commandés par le capitaine en brousse
c'est lui qui est brûlé au deuxième
degré dans l'incendié de la paillote le
gps des bases et ajaccio il a trois
missions
tout d'abord le renfort le maintien de
l'ordre ensuite l'escorté la protection
de personnalités menacées
enfin et c'est la mission la plus
inhabituel la recherche de
renseignements et l'observation pour
cette dernière mission
le peloton a été équipée selon le
journal le monde par la dgse les
services secrets français en matériel
très sophistiqué des coupes de pistage
et de surveillance
le gps prend ses ordres directement du
colonel mazères le patron des gendarmes
dans l'île ici en réunion à la
préfecture
le colonel a lui aussi été mis en examen
et écroué
une affaire qui intervient dans une
guerre entre gendarmes et policiers les
gendarmes étant soupçonné de ne pas
toujours partagé les renseignements
obtenus ce soir lionel jospin a annoncé
un réexamen de la structure du gps
olivier théron faisons un point ce soir
sur cette affaire dans d'abord le point
sur l'aspect judiciaire
et bien ce soir bien sûr avant le débat
contradictoire de demain donc le
quatrième homme norbert ambrosse qui a
été blessé vous l'avait dit lors de
l'incendié de cala d'oro zucchi depuis
soigner ses blessures à toulouse dans un
hôpital a été ramené sur l'île il serait
actuellement dans le cabinet du juge
d'instruction ou devrait lui être
signifiés c'est toujours à prendre au
conditionnel d'ailleurs sa mise en
examen il sa mise sous mandat dépôt donc
demain il y aurait quatre hommes dans le
cabinet du juge d'instruction pour le
débat contradictoire alors deuxième
aspect l'aspect plus proprement parler
politique car demain il va y avoir un
débat oui donc d'un point de vue
politique demain est un jour important
pour la corse puisque l'assemblée
territoriale sur réunis ici à ajaccio et
l'on attend on s'attend un tollé de la
part des nationalistes qui ont très très
mal supporté le soutien du gouvernement
envers le préfet bonnet donc ils ont
promis de déposer des amendements pour
demander à l'état d'aller jusqu'au bout
dans cette affaire il faudra aussi bien
sûr regardé le positionnement des partis
traditionnels surtout ceux de gauche
entre une opinion qui ne comprend pas
non plus toujours bien le soutien du
gouvernement aux préfets et la ligne des
partis politiques
merci olivier coïncidence du calendrier
le préfet de corse monsieur bernard
bonnet venu s'expliquer hier à paris au
ministère de l'intérieur et à matignon
était aujourd'hui à bastia aux côtés du
président de la cour des comptes
monsieur pierre joxe et l'on se souvient
que ce dernier fut ministre de
l'intérieur et qu'il eut lui aussi à
gérer la question corse reportage
michèle fines et franck vaillant
les photographes ne sont pas là pour
immortaliser l'audience solennelle de la
chambre régionale des comptes
mais pour le retour du préfet bonnet
convoqué hier au ministère de
l'intérieur bernard bonnet revenus
confirmé dans ses fonctions à sa grande
satisfaction
saoulé juste eu une phrase très très
très simple qui aident en étant malade
tempête de shakespeare une scène 5 ou ce
grand poète ce genivi ya une marée dans
les choses humaines et j'invite chacun à
bruz prudence une phrase sibylline mais
ponctuée d'une recommandation prudence
elle s'adresse entre autres au bâtonnier
d'ajaccio
antoine sollacaro avait demandé la
démission de bernard bonnet mais le
gouvernement a choisi de soutenir sont
pressés parce que vraiment presse
française stabilité
si on veut absolument dhr endosser la
responsabilité ce qui s'est passé
le leader des nationalistes jean guy
talamoni ne demande pas quant à lui le
départ de bernard bonnet mais un
changement de politique
la seule attitude raisonnable
aujourd'hui c'est de faire la clarté sur
cette affaire gravissime et c'est
surtout de changer de politique en corse
au delà du seul départ du profil qui
pressait bonnet qui n'est pas l'enjeu de
la question
l'enjeu c'est de changer de politique de
passer à une politique qui serait
respectueuse de la dignité des corses et
qui serait également respectueuse et
décisions des institutions de la course
dès demain sont attendus en corse les
deux inspections l'inspection générale
de l'administration se rendre à la
préfecture l'inspection générale des
armées se rendre à la gendarmerie
les missions de ces deux corps de
contrôle sont d'examiner ce que l'on
appelle la chaîne de commandement afin
de savoir qui finalement a donné l'ordre
aux gendarmes le conflit engagé au
kosovo et en serbie connaît depuis la
fin de l'après-midi un début de
bouleversements politiques et
diplomatiques slobodan milosevic a en
effet limogé son vice premier ministre
monsieur vu que draskovic qui
manifestaient depuis 48 heures des
velléités d'ouverture de négociation
marquant ainsi sa différence avec les
refus déterminé des autorités de
belgrade vue brajkovic fut longtemps un
opposant il avait rallié ce que vaut
elle mieux et vite symbolisant ainsi
l'union du peuple serbe face aux
bombardements
il est maintenant de retour dans
l'opposition explications jean-marc il
use
il avait osé dénoncer publiquement je
cite les mensonges de l'état de guerre
sur invincibilité serbe et contre l'avis
du président milosevic appelait depuis
trois jours à un rôle pour l'onu au
kosovo vous grâce kovic vice-premier
ministre fédéral a donc été limogé cet
après-midi pour atteinte au prestige du
gouvernement de slobodan milosevic qu'il
avait cru pouvoir amener un compromis
plus souple avec l'otan par
l'intermédiaire des russes un défi vite
sanctionnée par le pouvoir serbe mais
voudra ce kovic écrivain nationaliste et
chantre de la souffrance serbes pendant
la deuxième guerre mondiale est un
habitué des coups de tête entre 93 et 95
il organisera les rares manifestations
condamnant les excès des milices serbes
en bosnie
en 97 il fédérera un moment le rêve
d'une démocratie à l'européenne desserte
des grandes villes appauvris par le
conflit et assoiffés de liberté
d'expression mais en 98 son ambition
conduire à l'ex chef de l'opposition
nationaliste à se rallier à slobodan
milosevic au nom de l'union sacrée
autour du kosovo il devra donc cohabiter
avec cet homme vaut slash échelle
vice-premier ministre national de
milosevic un ultra nationaliste violent
qui l'avait qualifié naguère de chiens
assis depuis ce soir voilà de nouveau
vous grâce qu'aux geeks hors jeu il
vient d'annoncer à belgrade qu'il devra
désormais rentré dans le rang grâce au
vif méconnaissable qui céderaient fait
aujourd'hui à lille du parti du
renouveau du peuple serbe premier mini
millions écrivain a même cru bon
d'ajouter ne croyez pas qu'il y ait chez
nous de la division nous sommes tous
unis contre l'agression de l'otan
c'était fini les critiques le drap
slovic contre la militarisation du
régime
cette voix de modération cette voie
d'espoir qu'elle incarne et gratuit est
aujourd'hui le suivant étape
voilà pour les menaces de renaud girard
je marque il use quelles sont les
conséquences est qu'on peut les analyser
vu de paris débute à la première
conséquence est celle que vient de
relever un instant le ministère français
des affaires étrangères c'est à dire que
pour tous ceux qui se demandaient si oui
ou non en vrai ce kovic parler au nom
des autorités à belgrade
la réponse est cinglante son limogeage
c'est un nom de slobodan milosevic par
exemple assez proposition d'introduction
d'une force des nations unies au kosovo
alors sur le plan politique l'intérieur
sur cet échiquier un peu bizarre et un
peu artificielle de la politique de
sabre qui va d'une extrême gauche
archéo communiste incarnée par les
pousses de monsieur milosevic
jusqu'à une extrême-droite violente ils
ont voilà maintenant disparu la droite
nationaliste modéré de vaud brajkovic
vuk draskovic absents monsieur milosevic
pourra donc durcir son régime notamment
vis-à-vis de tous ceux qui dans les
villes elles sont nombreux rêves d'un
régime - militarisé que ceux qui n'ont
pas oublié que finalement la yougoslavie
en dix ans a perdu
les deux tiers de ces états que deux
cent mille serbes l'on vit souvent ont
été chassés ont dû quitter aussi les
pays qu'ils devaient conquérir et que
finalement ce pays c'est appauvrit
considérablement
donc si vous voulez y ait un vrai climat
de questionnement sur la politique de me
les sévices qui s'est manifesté mais
pour l'instant difficile de penser qu'
on peut aller plus loin est ce que pour
autant c'est la fin de ce que
j'appellerais une parenthèse de
contestation écoutez cette parenthèse à
d'abord eu lieu c'est important je ne
pense pas que demain les anciens
partisans de vuk draskovic vont
descendre en masse dans la rue parce que
le patriotisme serbe rend délicat le
fait de prendre des positions de
négociation pendant un conflit
même si beaucoup le souhaiterait disons
que pour l'instant la parenthèse doit
être digérée par la société serbe et que
comme le disait tout à l'heure un
diplomate téléphone tout cela n'est pas
très positif merci jean marc keller vue
grâce au beach exclu du gouvernement
c'est aussi une carte qui ne peut plus
être jouée par moscou et victor
tchernomirdine l'envoyé spécial de boris
eltsine qui doit se rendre dès demain à
bonn rome et belgrade
la difficulté pour la russie cette
trouver la bonne méthode pour peser sur
slobodan milosevic hydra bin oui claude
on peut dire si vous voulez que toutes
ces visites à moscou et tous ces
entretiens aujourd'hui avait un but
commun ce but commun était d'entendre en
vo en version originale le compte rendu
de la mission du médiateur victor démé
redit jeudi dernier à belgrade mission
qui vous en souvenez se déterminent
fermiers dans la plus grande confusion
et bien ce soir la tonalité générale à
moscou est très pessimiste pas de percée
dans la recherche de solutions pas de
signes de fléchissement de belgrade où
le limogeage de route jusqu'au but
montre que ce pessimisme qui l'avait
prouvé mais cela dit moscou a profité de
ce ballet diplomatique pour clarifier sa
position et sa méthode
nous ne sommes pas des facteurs qui
porterait des ultimatums d'un camp à
l'autre abivie igor ivanov le ministre
russe des affaires étrangères
renvoyant ainsi sur d'autres la
responsabilité du surplace diplomatique
actuelle mais c'est ôter aussi une
manière d'avouer que la russie n'avait
pas de solution d'ailleurs ce soir à
l'issue de son tout dernier entretien
avec son homologue grec
igor ivanov tentaient encore de laisser
croire dans un style très langue de bois
qu'il restait encore des pistes à
explorer quand le ministre grec des
affaires étrangères georges papandréou
l'a coupé net en déclarant je cite
notamment
si on avait une solution on vous
l'aurait déjà dit merci beaucoup j le
secrétaire général des nations unies
monsieur kofi annan se rend dès ce soir
à moscou il s'est entretenu aujourd'hui
à berlin avec le chancelier allemand
monsieur gerhardt schröder pour ce
coffee annan une solution durable au
kosovo ne pourra être gagnée sur le
champ de bataille
autre élément modifiant peut-être la
donne politique la rencontre entre le
président serbe monsieur milutinovic et
le chef modérée des albanais du kosovo
ibrahim rugova on ne sait toujours pas
si ce dernier virer véritablement libre
de ses mouvements et de sa parole mais
selon les autorités serbes les deux
hommes auraient convenu de rechercher un
accord politique
après cinq semaines de frappes et de
bombardements l'aviation des pays
membres de l'otan poursuit la
destruction des cibles serbe
et comme la guerre ne se fait jamais
proprement une bombe est tombé sur un
quartier résidentiel de la ville de sur
dix huit chats à 250 km au sud de
belgrade
le temps a exprimé des regrets commenté
françois corner c'est la nouvelle erreur
de l'aube temps une bombe ou un missile
qualifié d' armes de précision par un
porte parole de l'alliance n'a pas été
guidé par le faisceau laser du chasseur
bombardier sur la cible désignée et
s'est écrasé sur ce quartier résidentiel
de survie knicks à une ville de 10000
habitants au sud de belgrade
l'objectif visé à la périphérie de sueur
de l'idsa était un centre d'entraînement
de l'armée yougoslave dans les
baraquements se trouvait à deux ou trois
cents mètres de ce quartier le
casernement bien été détruits précise
l'otan il était vide au moment du raid a
ajouté un diplomate de l'alliance ce
n'était pas le cas ici depuis la nuit
dernière les sauveteurs ont retiré des
décombres les corps de 16 victimes pour
la plupart des femmes et des enfants
selon la télévision serbe pendant ce
temps l'amérique mobilise ses
réservistes et franchit une nouvelle
étape importante dans son engagement
contre belgrade au sein de l'otan
deux mille hommes et femmes ont été déjà
quitté les états unis plus de 30 mille
autres seront mobilisés au fur à mesure
des besoins confirmé le pentagone
ces réservistes serviront principalement
dans l'air force aux commandes des
avions ravitailleurs pour en assurer
aussi la logistique
ces renforts sont destinées à maintenir
plus longtemps l'air les chasseurs
bombardiers alliés au dessus de la
yougoslavie dans le but d'intensifier
les frappes aériennes
de jour comme de nuit en début d'après
midi l'aviation de l'otan a mené une
série de bombardements à 5 km au sud-est
de podgorica au monténégro contre deux
aéroports civils et militaires le port
de bar dans lequel est mouillé la flotte
yougoslave n'a pas été attaquée l'otan à
l'intention de dissuader les navires de
livrer du pétrole la barre plutôt que de
s'attaquer aux infrastructures du port
dans duquesne vous êtes à podgorica la
capitale du monténégro vous nous
confirmer ces bombardements et les
réactions je suppose du gouvernement
indépendant tout à fait alors il ya eu
donc deux vagues de bombardements vers
13h et 17h pas très loin d'ici dans
cette direction à environ 5 km sur deux
cibles dirais presque habituelle de
l'otan au sens où ce n'est pas la
première fois qu'elles sont bombardés la
première c'est une base militaire où la
deuxième armée serbe disposerait d'un
tunnel
vous serez stockés dans le monde
matériel militaire on dit même des
avions et des hélicoptères minustah bien
sûr n'est pas confirmée en tout cas
cette cible a été bombardée puis l'autre
cycle classique entre limes et les
reports civils et militaires qui sont
côte à côte tout cela c'est produit donc
de façon très intensive par rapport à ce
qu'on a connu jusqu'à présent
et les réactions ici sont bien sûr
mitigé personne ne peut se réjouir de
bombardements que ce soit au monténégro
en serbie bien sûr les opposants à
milosevic encore moi parce qu'ils
craignent bien sûr les conséquences que
peuvent avoir ces bombardements sur la
population
et puis les les partisans milosevic eux
et bien ça ne fait que redoubler leur
leurs revendications alors il faut
rappeler qu'effectivement montenegro
fait partie de la république fédérale de
yougoslavie
avez vous des nouvelles de notre
confrère journaliste camerling de tf1
eric vaillant qui est détenu je crois
depuis le 20 avril le monténégro par les
forces serbes
absolument et on est relativement
inquiet soul et parce que pour deux
raisons d'abord on ne comprend pas du
tout les raisons pour lesquelles il a
été arrêté je vous rappelle ça se
passait dans le nord près de la
frontière avec le kosovo et quelques
veillant à ce moment là à les filmer
un village où avait lieu un assemblée un
incident assez assez grave mais il y
allait avec la protection de la police
monténégrine il est arrêté par la
deuxième armée fédérale donc pourquoi
personne ne le sait et la deuxième
raison qui fait qu'on est un petit peu
inquiet c'est que l'interprète qui
avaient été arrêtés avec lui a été
libéré hier soir et en principe convoqué
pour un éventuel procès convoqué comme
témoin pour témoigner contre contre éric
vaillant alors ce concept ses conditions
de détention d'après ce que j'ai pu le
savoir
en discutant avec les collègues de tf1
hier soir il est maintenant dans une
prison civile il n'a pas été maltraité
il est tenu à l'écart dans une cellule
isolée à l'abri bien sûr des détenus de
droit commun
merci maintenant on redoute le pire non
loin de la frontière entre le kosovo et
l'albanie pour la première fois depuis
plus de dix jours des milliers de
nouveaux réfugiés ceux venus de la ville
de djokovic qui est située à 50 km à
l'intérieur du kosovo ont franchi la
frontière près de morina ils sont venus
à pied
nos envoyés spéciaux clos 200 paires et
bernie mériaux ont écouté leurs
témoignages sur des massacres d
exécution des dizaines des centaines de
jeunes hommes auraient été séparés de
leur famille mais impossible de savoir
précisément ce qui s'est passé à
quelques dizaines de kilomètres de
mourinho ils ont marché plus de 50
kilomètres pendant deux jours ce sont
leurs derniers pas vers la liberté
ils viennent tous de plusieurs villages
autour de la ville d'auch djakovica au
kosovo chassé par les milices et les
paramilitaires serbes
quelques minutes après leur arrivée les
premiers ont commencé à me parler
ce qui arrive est avocat
ils ont tué des hommes ils ont tué les
hommes les femmes les enfants et plus il
les a sortis des maisons les enduits on
m'a rien au tout début quand ces
réfugiés nous racontent leur histoire
il est impossible de leur demander ce
qu'ils ont bien vu tout ce qu'il dit
deux heures plus tard sur la route nous
parlerons très longtemps avec un petit
groupe d'entre eux pour essayer d'en
savoir plus
on est parti hier matin il y eu des
personnes maltraitées tous les jeunes
ans était arrêté environ 400 500 ils
sont restés là bas à l'arrière du
tracteur nous apercevons un homme jeune
il affirme s'être cachés ou sont tous
les tous les maris tous les frères des
femmes qui sont derrière vous tous les
hommes ont été mis à terre couché dans
les champs des villages de may a aidé au
push mais mes horizons et la femme
ajoute ils ont tiré des rafales tout ce
qu'ils pouvaient même sur des enfants de
16 ans à l'arrière de la remorque
une autre femme de racontent la même
histoire des garçons et des hommes ils
les ont forcés à se coucher par terre on
ne sait pas ce qui leur arrivait
comment savoir comment être reçu en fin
d'après midi nous continuons
d'interroger ces réfugiés ceux qui ont
encore la force de raconter sont
questionnés de manière très précise qui
lui laissait en tuer ces 15 personnes
oui j'étais loin mais j'ai vu comment
les ont tués dans le dos de fins de
pinces et vous avez vu laissé en tuer
ses hommes cette interview durant plus
de six minutes avec toujours les mêmes
questions vous avez vu vous êtes sûr
c'est votre famille votre maison à cette
heure il est difficile d'en savoir plus
sur ces différents massacres commis
d'hier dans la région de djakovica le
hcr est en train de recouper tous les
témoignages
dans l'après-midi des militaires serbes
imperturbable on fait un peu de ménage
ils ont enlevé la voiture de réfugiés
qui avait explosé il ya quelques jours
sur une mine faisant plusieurs victimes
pour ces militaires serbes la journée
d'aujourd'hui fut tout simplement une
journée ordinaire en macédoine mais plus
précisément juste de l'autre côté de la
frontière avec le kosovo cinq réfugiés
ont été tués par l'explosion d'une mine
comme en albanie le nouvel afflux de
réfugiés s'accompagne également de
récits des exactions commises selon les
kosovars par les forces serbes dans les
camps macédonien la tension est extrême
car les conditions de vie sont
intenables en raison de la surpopulation
reportage richard binet patrick desmulie
il y a ceux qui sont déjà arrivés depuis
ce matin ils attendent devant le poste
frontière de glace chez un parent un
voisin ou un ami
quelques centaines de mètres seulement
les séparent mais c'est la déception
les réfugiés albanais sont immédiatement
entassés dans des bus alors on se l on
écrit sur les vitres le nom de son
village avant de partir pour à caen dont
on ne sait même pas le nom c'est ibrahim
saïdi d'inquiéter krillin cet emprunt la
ligne 1 je dois dire que vous êtes ici
avec toute la famille
depuis le début du conflit
la macédoine a accueilli 140 3000
réfugiés
c'est bien plus que le pays ne peut
supporter les responsables du hcr
craignent non seulement des épidémies
réseau si des émeutes
quand vous avez une telle concentration
de gens dans un espace aussi réduit tout
peut arriver qu'ils attendent beaucoup
de nous les gens sont très stressés car
il ne repartirait pas du camp aussi vite
qu'ils espéraient
c'est que ce var sont arrivés il ya
quelques heures à peine ils viennent
s'ajouter aux familles de réfugiés du
clan de blatche et à quelques kilomètres
de skopje où déjà les conditions de vie
sont extrêmes
oui
les catiches aussi sans catastrophe ça
fait trois semaines que je me suis pas
la veille mon fils est très malade il a
été suivi à l'hôpital où il avait la dia
s'est rendu au chili
on n'a presque rien avec nos vient
d'arriver et entre sacré très difficile
hier le président de la république de
macédoine qui rocky horror a sévèrement
critiqué les membres de l'otan ils leur
reprochent principalement d'avoir manqué
à leurs engagements en accueillant pas
suffisamment de réfugiés albanais
viatteau 14 à 15% de la population de la
macédoine sera constitué de réfugiés en
comparaison c'est comme si vous
demandiez d'allemagne l'accueillir du
jour au lendemain
six millions de personnes le camp de
brazza où nous sommes avait été prévu
pour accueillir vingt mille réfugiés
aujourd'hui ils sont plus de 30000 les
ong les autorités macédoniennes ne
peuvent plus faire face à ce nouvel
afflux la seule solution aujourd'hui
envisagée serait de les transférer en
albanie le pays le plus pauvre d'europe
ce qui reviendrait à déplacer le
problème un venu de macédoine ou
d'albanie plusieurs centaines de
réfugiés du kosovo sont arrivés à
marseille aujourd'hui ils ont été
dirigés vers des foyers d'accueil de la
région provence alpes côte d'azur
au total il y aura environ 1800 réfugiés
albanais déjà accueilli en france mais
l'accueil des albanais du kosovo ne se
fait pas aussi facilement qu annoncé dès
le début du conflit
certes la générosité des pays d'accueil
est grande mais il ya parfois des écarts
entre les promesses et les réalités que
ce soit en europe mais aussi et surtout
aux états unis
l'explication nathalie moison à l'aube
sur une côte italienne leurs passeurs
les a jetés sur le rivage 700 kosovars
sont ainsi parvenus près d'autres anti
hier matin combien de réfugiés ont gagné
l'italie de cette façon selon se payer
8000 personnes parmi lesquels 80 %
seraient d'origine kosovare beaucoup
plus officiel et médiatique et la
première arrivée de réfugiés au canada
hier
les autorités se disent prêtes à
accueillir 5000 personnes pour l'heure
seule une dizaine est arrivée des
promesses aux actes plus d'un mois après
le début des bombardements de l'otan
les pays de l'alliance nous pas tous
reçu des réfugiés à parts égales en
europe l'allemagne proposé d'en recevoir
dix mille seul ce pays a tenu ses
promesses
très tôt la turquie a construit un camp
capable de recevoir vingt mille
personnes
aujourd'hui 5100 réfugiés sont arrivés
en turquie la norvège ouvre ses portes à
6000 personnes elle n'a reçu pour
l'instant que 1500 de son côté la france
opposés aux quotas privilégie toujours
l'aide aux réfugiés sur place parce
qu'on doit pas donner cette arme à milo
chez bic de les faire partir au loin il
faut que les sentiments qu'ils puissent
rentrer chez eux
malgré tout la france continue de
recevoir des réfugiés 1800 aujourd'hui
ils seront 2500 dans notre pays le 1er
mai quant aux états unis qui volent et
hébergé 20000 kosovars en particulier
sur la base de guantanamo à cuba
ils ont enterré cette idée mais affirme
toujours vouloir en accueillir vingt
mille
alors cette guerre fait aussi des
réfugiés parmi la population serbe ils
sont passés en roumanie venant de
belgrade et de novi sad poursuivre les
bombardements de l'otan ils ont retrouvé
une partie de la communauté serbe
roumaine mais bien sûr ils ne
comprennent pas du tout le pourquoi de
cette guerre pourquoi ils sont obligés
de fuir les destructions causées par des
avions venus de pays qu'ils pensaient
amis reportage en berlin schmitt
dominique bonnet au delà de cette limite
le pays est en guerre depuis le début du
conflit le poste frontière entre la
serbie et la roumanie est désert le
trafic a cessé pourtant quelques 150
familles ont franchi ces barrières pour
fuir les bombardements et se réfugier
dans la région de timisoara des
associations locales les hais ces serbes
originaires de belgrade se sont
réfugiées ici parce qu'ils étaient sûrs
d'être accueillis par leurs frères
romain distiller in china j'ai attendu
jusqu'à la dernière minute avant de
partir j'ai réussi à passer la frontière
mais aujourd'hui je me sens rejeté par
tous sauf ma famille ils ont tout laissé
derrière eux
le plus souvent ils ne comprennent pas
les motifs de la guerre les plus anciens
eux croient encore aux amitiés du passé
nous aimons au fait français
nous n'avons pas oublié les deux
dernières guerres aux îles votre avis
c'est à dire serbie et la france
c'était deux soeurs qui combattaient
pour la liberté selon diana elle a
laissé son mari à novi sad
elle s'est enfuie avec sa fille chez des
amis de la famille attend je suis partie
du dos la vie parce que ma fille ne
supportait plus les bombardements g on
devait la laisser dans un grenier club
rhodanien stop on entendait les sirènes
et les explosions bravos do prado
c'était très vicieuse borgniet nice n'a
rien fait pour mériter cela
ce n'est pas nous qui avons commencé la
guerre avant les bombardements nous
étions tranquilles nous avions la tête
les réfugiés comme ce le ghana sont
plutôt bien accueillies dans la région
les habitants de timisoara se sentent en
effet très proche des cercles noirs une
balle entre peuples des balkans nous
avons des sentiments communs même si
nous sommes des peuples différents
mythes notamment par la langue
il ya beaucoup de choses qui nous lie
auxerre montreal un aujourd'hui ce le
ghana n'a qu'un espoir quitté la
roumanie rentrer chez elle et oublier
cette guerre dont elle ne cherche pas à
comprendre les raisons et pour la
première fois depuis le début des
bombardements par l'otan un attentat a
été perpétré contre l'alliance est des
états unis c'était à athènes l'attentât
a été revendiqué au nom de la lutte
contre l'impérialisme américain un mort
un blessé ces deux bilan de cet attentat
voilà pour l'acuité de de cette journée
concernant le conflit au kosovo
à gaza le conseil palestinien a suivi
son chef yasser arafat et décidé de
reporter après les élections
israéliennes la proclamation d'un état
indépendant en fonction donc des
résultats
mais pendant la période électorale
israélienne le gouvernement de monsieur
netanyahu laisse faire les nouvelles
implantations juives en cisjordanie
voici le constat avec le reportage de
charles enderlin c'est la multiplication
des colonies pour contourner les accords
d'oslo avec les palestiniens qui
interdisent la création de nouvelles
implantations
les colons et sème à partir des
localités existantes
par exemple ici près de la ville
palestinienne de naplouse des militants
se sont installés sur une colline
voisine de leur implantation
ils proviennent sur leurs terres ils
veulent y vivre
on a trouvé un bel endroit et on s'y
installe c'est tout simple
depuis les accords de wye plantation en
octobre dernier
vingt nouvelles implantations de ce
genre ont vu le jour en cisjordanie
alors que dans les colonies mer la
construction bat son plein voici ofra
près de ramallah
un nouveau quartier se termine et ici at
elle sillonne au nord de jérusalem il
100 appartements devrait être achevé
dans quelques mois
et ce n'est que la première tranche des
travaux en tout six mille unités de
logements doivent être construites ici
une véritable ville ultra orthodoxe est
en train de se construire à un quart
d'heure de ramallah ce renforcement de
la colonisation de suscite pourtant que
des condamnations verbales de la part
des dirigeants palestiniens
les provocations israéliennes sont le
signal non seulement de la fin du
processus de paix mais aussi d'une
période de confrontation
ils disent tous palestiniens qu'israël a
renoncé à ses engagements en fait
autorité palestinienne empêche toute
manifestation contre les implantations
dans l'entourage de yasser arafat donc a
en effet des actes de violence qui
donneraient des arguments à benyamin
nétanyahou à trois semaines les
élections en israël
en attendant les implantations juives
s'étendent en france une image politique
celle de charles de gaulle petit fils du
général député européen élu sur la liste
de philippe de villiers en 94 il
figurera aux côtés de jean marie le pen
pour les élections du 13 juin prochain
sur cette même liste outre fera donc
charles de gaulle on trouvera aussi
d'anciens militants os la couverture
maladie universelle cmu est un projet de
loi qui prévoit l'accès aux soins pour
les plus pauvres
accès aux soins entièrement gratuit les
députés examinent en ce moment le projet
du gouvernement
mais à gauche comme à droite on exprime
des divergences sur le seuil de revenu
au dessous duquel cet accès sera permis
reportage en pole chapelle et
jean-françois chevet il y a là une
inégalité de jours a de chance pour ce
député rpr
le jour où ils montent au créneau contre
la couverture maladie univers
tél il est mal à ce sourire sur les
bancs de l'assemblée
il n'est pas facile de s'en prendre à un
texte offrant la gratuité des soins pour
les plus pauvres
la cmu permettra à 150000 exclu
d'accéder au régime de base de la sécu
mieux encore les six millions de
français les plus démunis pourront
bénéficier d'une couverture
complémentaire gratuite
une condition avoir des revenus
inférieurs à 3500 francs par mois
c'est le principe de ce seuil que les
députés de l'opposition conteste alors
vous avez 3500 francs par mois
votre voisin on à 3600 mais lui il aura
pas droit à la couverture maladie
universelle
alors que vous vous y aurez droit c'est
évidemment une injustice profonde et
nous allons la dénoncer à gauche les
verts et les communistes acceptent
l'idée du seuil
mais le jugent trop bas quel plafond
3800 francs pas 3500 3800 francs
tous les organismes internationaux
disent c'est le seuil de pauvreté
si on veut aider les ports il faut
prendre en compte le fait de pauvreté
pour martine aubry l'important est de
mettre fin à un demi-siècle de
résignation le seuil choisi par le
gouvernement est juste mais pas immuable
quand nous regardons d'ailleurs lé seuil
de pauvreté défini par les organismes
internationaux ou nationaux
nous avons une foultitude si je puis
dire de seuil qui vont être définir les
seuils de pauvreté de trois mille 3000
2,3 1005ha 3008
nous avons choisi ce seuil de 3000 5 je
suis prêt bien évidemment à en discuter
les députés ont jusqu'à mardi prochain
pour achever l'examen du texte qui sera
ensuite transmis au sénat
poursuite du mouvement de grève à la
sncf engagés par les agents de conduite
à propos du projet d'accord sur les 35
heures certains tgv nord ont été
perturbé en banlieue parisienne
plusieurs trains rer ont été supprimés
le trafic sera également perturbé demain
du sport du football la finale de la
coupe de france opposera le 15 mai
prochain au stade de france sedan club
de deuxième division ou fc nantes qui
évolue en première division
en effet battu nîmes 1-0 sur ce but
marqué par nicolas savinaud à la 75e
minute
la dernière partie de ce journal se fera
en musique avec la sortie du deuxième
album du groupe gallois stereophonics
ils sont en tournée en france c'est le
25 mai ils se produiront à l'olympia à
paris issu d'un petit village du pays de
galles ses trois garçons n'ont pas mis
bien longtemps pour trouver des
centaines de milliers de fans
présentation frédéric bonnet et roger
motte
parce que
et pourtant il ne s'agit que d'un
premier concert il y a deux ans à peine
stereophonics ne voulait rien dire à
personne pas même aux anglais
aujourd'hui ce groupe en flammes toute
une génération
belle chevauchée fantastique pour cette
bande de trois boys sortie du même
village gallois et qui refuse
l'appellation boys band
je ne pense pas que nous soyons un
produit je pense d'abord nous voulons
jouer correctement et en rimes
le système est ainsi fait il ya de plus
en plus de rencontrer le téléjournal de
radio- 7e questions de fond qu rentable
j'explique à moins de corps repêchés sur
les traces du succès des beatles il
avoue tout de même qu'ils sont les rock
stars dont ils se sont inspirés et si
d'ici bob dylan les sex pistols on a
puisé dans nos collections de disques
elvis costello 6
et si kelly stewart richardson ont de
l'or entre les doigts c'est sans doute
parce que ces trois garçons ont déjà
vendu leur premier album à plus de
400000 exemplaires
au delà
dieu
walibi qu'est ce que vous voulez devenir
l'égal match aussi important que
manchester united aussi grands créateurs
eiffel tout le monde connaît la tour
eiffel puis nous trois jeunes gallois
viennent de conquérir le coeur des
français
il nous montre que le rock britannique
sait comment se renouveler et qu'il sait
aussi dans quelle direction se trouve le
succès
théréau phonique si on vous pose la
question surtout ne rougissez plus vous
pouvez dire maintenant que vous les
connaissez un peu
changer
voilà avant de refermer ce journal je
vous rappelle deux informations que nous
avons développées tout d'abord
concernant la corse notre spécial
ajaccio olivier théron l'annonçait c'est
confirmé le capitaine norbert ambrose
commandant du groupe des pelotons de
sécurité a été mis en examen et écrouée
à ajaccio pour destruction volontaire de
biens appartenant à autrui par l'effet
d'un incendie comme hyper bande
organisée plusieurs membres du
gouvernement dont le premier ministre
lionel jospin s'exprime sur la corse et
l'incarcération de gendarmes compromis
donc dans la sphère de la destruction du
restaurant de la plage de d'ajaccio pour
le chef du gouvernement c'est la sphère
de l'état ne serait pas une affaire
d'état à belgrade slobodan milosevic
limoges son bistrot nice lutte draskovic
russie souhaitait l'ouverture de
négociations le président clinton
annonce une intensification des frappes
en macédoine et en albanie
de nouveau des milliers de réfugiés
affluent de nombreux témoignages font
état de massacres ou d'exécution par
dizaines par centaines commis par les
serbes
dans quelques secondes la météo avec
sophie davant puis un nouvel épisode de
la série les monos à 22h40 vous
retrouvez jean luc delarue pour ça se
discute le dernier journal vous sera
présenté à zéro heure 50 par florence
duprat suivi du circle des critiques de
philippe lefait demain 7h 50 dans les 4
vérités françoise laborde recevra
françois léotard et à 13h vous trouverez
rachid arhab à demain 20 heures vont
soir merci